oh no Sarah it is
[Music]
I love my mother
ate my brother
so let's get after it and have us
it's a good [__] bread
so uh I've had people message me going
like that song's in my head sometimes I
sing it to my wife she gets mad at me
it really does it gets it drills into
your brain so
what are we up to we're on the chomo
project no no this is this is this is
trouble oh no I don't know he's got so
many things he's still all over the
place wait till you see who he's
interviewing
so let's have the conversation right now
I bring in cartoonist author creator of
Dilbert host of the YouTube show real
coffee with Scott Adams the man he's the
only guy that's had him on I got look I
mean whatever I know he's trying to get
whatever he can but he's the only guy
that had him on right thank you very
much for taking the opportunity
hey thanks for having me Chris
all right so let's get the big things
out of the way
um people who are new to the situation
and have heard that one sound bite say
the guy's racist uh what do you say to
people who heard that and say well Chris
they're probably blacks
uh well Chris I'd probably say you know
you're Italian so lecture me about being
a racist have you seen a documentary
called True Romance
hey
Scott Adams is right from [__] WAP
has to say
start you
No in fact I often say it would be
stupid to judge people anyway other than
individually you would just be hurting
yourself you'd just be cutting yourself
off from you know half of the good
people in the world or some number so so
judging people by anything other than
their individual character never makes
sense and certainly I wouldn't say that
did you know that this was going to
happen but Chris
um I intentionally courted uh
controversy which is we knew that by the
way because people a lot of new people
on it is don't understand merge Shania
and Virgie we've been following Scott
Scott Adams things for a couple years
now
this is his thing this is what he does
on Twitter yeah he's a little contrarian
[__] the covet stuff he does and [__]
like that where he tries to be like oh
what am I doing no I'm so I'm so I'm
such a philosopher like I'm not just a
the problem is is that Scott Adams has
been trying his whole life not to be
known as the Dilbert guy right and he
and you you'll even see like the
weakness that comes out here in a second
right where
watch watch but it's something I do
often in my live streams and I was
trying to attract attention so that I
could have a productive argument now
look here Sky look no one likes movies
in the neighborhood any less than me all
right my community is gated I get it but
you can't just say that on the news you
know what I mean like people are going
to get mad at you you focus one thing
when you're with family you know and you
make you know it's okay it's fine you
know but uh yeah I can't say that [__]
on the internet yeah you know you can
say that when you're talking to your
Nona and stuff you know like that's
that's how they are you know the old
country but like not over here you know
now there's a frame or a context here
that probably almost none of your
audience is familiar with oh yeah
because you're I get it you're smart
you're a big brain I'll have you know
that all 32 000 people that watch this
video are probably familiar and that
would really change well you don't
understand is I'm an intellectual I said
those racist things to court attention
and you gave it to me I win it's like no
that's still pretty yeah but the problem
is it's Cuomo so it's like yeah you know
but I'm also an intellectual you got to
see my walking talks okay yeah and don't
ask me about the [__] bird stop
asking me about look I know a little
thing about controversy I go out there I
kill a couple birds and all of a sudden
this [__] podcast is about to make a
fun of me now I'm a [__] bad guy now
I'm the bad guy because I killed two
three four hundred Birds
a lot of birds
see this could I give you a little
context
please that's what the whole
conversation's about Scott give me the
context all right all right so if you
knew me as a Cartoonist and all you
heard was the headline you did a racist
rant and then you heard the video
there's really no other way to interpret
it than the worst possible way and I
would agree with that
but if you knew me as what I'm probably
more probably had more impact on the
world is some of these books which are
from philosophy to persuasion to how to
how to deal with this situation actually
and other online controversies and
arguments but this one's the most
effective one and this is in the domain
of uh personal growth personal success
so I'm actually one of the most
um I would say noted people in the field
of success and the the tools of success
in fact if somebody wrote a book it
might have success today well I'm sorry
my bad word he just it's just he's a
smug [__] you got to be more specific
which one oh sorry yeah this time Scott
Adams okay actually Cuomo has has been
far more likable really well because
he's next to Scott Adams true
they would almost have to reference my
work it's it's pretty much pervasive in
other work as well
so if you knew that my uh background
included being a hypnotist
guys he's he's lost his mind he's a
hypnotist and he's and he's socially
hypnotizing us so he lost the vax made
him go crazy and then the thing with
that sugar baby he was dating made him
go crazy like he's just broken right
yeah he's just Snappy if you knew that I
work in the self-development specific
individual uh you know individual
success field and that I've noted for
that individual and you know that I like
to court controversy because that's part
of persuasion you do a little hypers
part of persuasion see that's what he is
he's a he's another Scott Adams is
another [__] pseudo-intellectual he's
in the same vein as a [__] as a
Jordan Peterson you know
it's the same thing really your energy
comes to you and then you reframe it
well wait is that there was a call-in
number
you could have called in and talked to
Scott Adams well we've been saying that
Cuomo does the calling thing we've been
telling people to keep an eye out yeah
but who wants to sit there and watch
Como is what I'll do today for your your
guests uh then you reframe it and then
everybody leaves happy so that that was
the model what I did not count on is
that the uh that my audience uh which is
you they know me so they would know what
I was up to in fact they knew right away
as soon as I said it my audience said
all right what are you doing what kind
of play is this what's what's the long
game and of course I was explaining it
to him the entire time but what happened
was it got bigger than I expected it
became a you know worldwide cancellation
so I had to wait a little while let let
all the the noise dissipate let the
energy dissipate a little bit and then I
thought well this is about the time and
you're actually kind of the perfect
person to talk to because I think I
appreciate you taking the opportunity
off the hook
you know
there's a delay yeah go ahead but just
Scott while you're getting whatever you
want
um the I just want people to know you
know I called you because I said I got
to know why you were doing this uh
because I know you work and you're too
smart and I've never ever heard you
saying things that were like David Duke
um Doctor Doctor David Duke you put some
respect
on his name he didn't go to six years of
white supremacist college and not to be
called doctor and you had to know look
out now man Cuomo learned your super
secret name that's either myself nor
Royce will ever refer to you as
damn it Cuomo
would be huge and that the intentions
would be assumed they're calling they're
calling Scott Adams Dilbert Duke so I
had to know why you did it yeah and
that's why I have you on tonight yeah so
tell me right right so that so obviously
the hyperbole I used get away from black
people there's no way to do that
hahaha
okay you're not
he's
I will give you this you are good at
hypnotizing me Scott Adams
this entire thing is hypnotizing
and you know I don't even recommend it
it's not really a good idea so that's
what makes it high energy it's sort of
like when Trump says if the windmills if
the wind stops blowing and the windmills
stop turning your TV won't work I'm
pretty sure he knows that's not the case
but it makes everybody go what are you
wrong you don't understand and then all
the energy comes to him so I've read I
don't know that he knows that but you do
because you're like a smart guy you know
yeah not me I'm smarter than Trump you
know that's why I've been fighting every
job
sir you're on news Nation doing an
interview with the creator of Dilbert
because he's too racist to be on CNN now
you're not exactly winning either there
Chris
but you do and you're not going to get
the defense that he will you know with
Trump people sometimes write him off by
look he just says things you're a smart
guy who just says things
he's not that smart the problem is he's
such a [__] dumb [__] right he's just
dumb Guido that when he thinks
somebody's just somebody manipulates you
that means they're Geniuses they're
[__] the guy's genius you understand
like he said he says words but you know
what he means the opposite yeah he
swerved you this guy's [__] you know
what he's [__] the boys [__] Chris
Cuomo's Vince Russo yeah he's worth
working all the boys
I mean we've all been reading and
watching for years so you knew it was
going to go like this and you still
don't know listen bro bro you don't
understand bro when I was saying the
n-word and stuff and talking about I
don't like black people bro I was being
controversial bro
I was trying to get ratings bro we were
losing a raw by like one point
no I knew it would go uh it would create
controversy in a small way but I thought
it would stay within my own who's Dumber
right now on the screen
Chris Cuomo okay yeah yeah he's a dumber
one right yeah Scott's just a spurg
y
Scott's one of those guys that he's not
[__]
but he's not smart enough to realize
that he is kind of [__] you know
what I mean
so [__] [__] so somebody's calling
it if that's your headline yeah you so
people don't get mad at me now Tampa
Florida
Tom thank you for making the call Tom
from Tampa's calling in let's see
thank you glad to be on hi Chris hi
Scott uh well first off I want to say
Ramon get the silver guy oh God could
you imagine what a throwback I know
a question for Scott Scott how do you
respond to the people who take your
hyperbole literally and use it to
justify their own racist views or
actions who who the [__] is who the [__]
is saying like well I wasn't gonna beat
up this black guy
but the Dilbert guy told me do who's
doing that no he's saying
uh he's talking about like the black
people on Twitter that were like oh yeah
well like [__] [__] Scott Adams he's
just a [__] [__] white dude a honky
that's honky I don't know man I don't
really pay attention to those people
when they crack up yeah cracker
[Laughter]
yeah he said I did the hyperbole hear me
out it's gonna [__] you up
Scott Adams
Aldo and Benjamin
look at it I think he's gonna slow he's
slowly gonna go out and he looks like
him too look really because I was trying
to rile people up I didn't expect it to
get this big so yeah you did you said
that in the first part
I guess in the first part you wanted it
you said you were courting controversy
oh I hate him it's a weird cope dude
yeah it is a very weird cope
it wasn't a hyperbole you very
succinctly said he
study I am extrapolating this study to
say that most black people don't really
like white people therefore I'm gonna
take the logical conclusion and just not
be around black people how the [__] is
that hyperbole
um I don't think he knows what that word
means
I got what I asked for in a sense that
uh you know I knew people would
misinterpret I knew something you know
get the get the right Vibe I wanted to
get fired I didn't even want to be on
all the newspapers if you want to do
anything successful in this category you
pretty much have to nail yourself to a
cross and you know I didn't think it
would come to this you know I thought
it'd be like one nail but apparently I
got the whole the whole three nails
but to people who are white extremists
who are saying Adams is with us do you
want to disabuse them of that notion
no one really believes that um people
that are doing that are doing it
ironically yeah because it's funny
you're an idiot nobody everybody here's
the thing
anybody who really knew what was going
on got the context we knew what it was
doing nobody thinks Dilbert doesn't like
black people it's got absolutely black
people that no one thinks that actually
this is just it was a joke because it's
a funny joke to put Dilbert in like
falling down or you know what I mean or
it's just became a meme white
supremacists don't really sit there go
that's right boy Scott Adams is on our
side
no one's doing that nobody it's it was
definitely meant to be yeah because we
can Photoshop you with [__] you know
on the [__] what's his face from
American history yeah and it's funny
it's just a funny joke
hey yes I I disavow all uh all the
racists uh whoever they are no matter
what color they are right I disavow all
racism always have always will but but
let me let me give just a little context
there are plenty of things that I
consider racist that I do approve of for
example historically black colleges
feels a little racist totally approved
paste sort of a Black History Month
feels a little a little bit racist to
some people totally approved black
people should get their own month makes
perfect sense in the in light of
American History
um take affirmative action I lost two
jobs in my corporate life because my
bosses told me they wouldn't promote me
because the word had come down that they
couldn't promote white to males
that actually happened in a direct
conversation from two different bosses
and two companies and still and still I
approve of affirmative action you know
he's such a saint yeah are you a good
guy he's such a good guy approve of the
thing you just said is not fair and
gross and you also said that it's that
it's racist but it's okay so racism is
okay sometimes
yeah he's a hypnotist no your word
you're looking for is hypocrite yeah
that was the word there it is oh he's
dyslexic yeah
which is weird for a comic strip right
yeah because I went out and got another
job although I listened and by the way
all you people that are reading Dilbert
think that this guy's just joking listen
I've read every Dilbert and I've never
laughed so this guy's not joking okay
uh you know what corporate likes like
your ties always up your dog works with
you it's just like real life
it's always up your hair looks like a
Zoomer now who cares
[__] these two these two are idiots
um and that doesn't matter No One's
Gonna See this except us because we're
just like making fun of Christmas okay